hey leute was sie da und herzlich
willkommen beim einem ersten video hier
auf meine neuen kanal
[Musik]
ich habe mir überlegt dass mein erstes
video unbedingt 21 fakten video sein
sollte und ich weiß auch dass diese
ganze geschichte ist schon ziemlich
ausgelutscht ist aber solche franken
videos sind halt echt richtig gut um
mich besser kennenzulernen sagt mal ich
weiß auch dass mitspielen jetzt sagt
dass wir nicht wie wir schon und ich
mich schon gefragt haben wo ich vor dem
halt ja oder so viele videos gemacht
habe aber auch für die oder für die die
jetzt leute das super dazu kommen es
halt echt wirklich mut mich halt noch
besser kennenzulernen oder halt anfangen
kennenzulernen sage ich mal
ich will doch nicht nur gelassen und
wird direkt man sagen wir kommen zum
ersten tag ich bin alex für 15 jahre alt
und werde im september 16
es gab es ja noch keinen monat in dem
ich nicht mindestens eine woche erkältet
war
ich hatte vor circa einem jahr mal lange
haare unser einfach mal total scheiße
aus ich esse pro tag wirklich meistens
so drei maß und ich war dies ja in den
sommerferien zum dreizehnten mal auf die
gleiche insel
das komische ist dass ich für echt so
jeden tag mindestens fünf bis acht
stunden gezockt hat und heutzutage
einfach mal gar nicht mehr von der xbox
nicht auf mein zimmer oder von meinem pc
irgendwas zocker sondern einfach nur
noch da jetzt auch nicht unbedingt wenig
dran hänge aber das auch nur weil ich
halt wie sagt man so facebook um
installieren sich bringen ich esse pro
woche ungefähr so zweimal macdonald und
zwei mal pizza und das gut ist ich werde
mein halber tag bestehen eigentlich soll
darin dass musik hören
meistens so einfach diese spotify charts
von 130 runter und wieder hoch aber halt
manchmal so ein gangster wollte ich mal
in peking
ich bin zwar schon 15 aber mir kommt das
irgendwie manchmal so vor als wäre der
auf der anderen seite kommen danach war
auch irgendwie manchmal so vor als wenn
ich schon viel erwachsener
ich kann eigentlich relativ gut ich habe
spielen kommen jetzt auch darauf an wie
man das wort mut definiert aber ich habe
auf jeden fall früher hat zwei jahren
der musikschule gespielt und viel halt
auch jetzt manchmal zurück wir nicht
wenn ich plane mit youtube hätte ich
mich eigentlich sehr gut aus leicht
glaube ich so meinen ersten kanal mit
ungefähr elf bis zwölf jahren erstellt
habe irgendwann bin ich dann an slogan
gekommen und ich glaube ich habe auf
meinem letzten kanal nach ungefähr ein
halbes oder retten ja was 3000
abonnenten oder ein knapp 3000
abonnenten und auch eine partnerschaft
ich habe mir vor zwei wochen erst mal
dass es vier mini gekauft weil mein
altes handy irgendwie so lange zum
ausland wollten
ich esse passiert das mittagessen
einfach mal mit apfelkompott von mir das
irgendwie dann nochmal ich liebe es
einfach auf facebook eben der scheiße zu
posten weil ich echt verdammt lang her
will dass du dich auch so offen zu aber
ist ja auch nix schlimmes denke ich mal
und deswegen gebe ich auch diese leute
die jeden scheiß haben wir leichen egal
wie sinnlos ist wenig auf sie zutrifft
und blablabla auch wenn ein film
langweilig ist kommt ihm irgendwie
trotzdem wir bis zum ende da ich immer
denke nach dieser szene kommt
so regen was spannendes dann legt zwar
fast immer falsch aber pech gehabt
ich habe wirklich noch nie geraucht
alkohol getrunken oder angesagt und wenn
du mir das nicht von ihrem einen kanal
und das war's auch schon mit dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch einigermaßen
gefallen und ihr das wirklich noch da
wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollte alles
sind facebook und installieren wollen in
der video beschreibung
da könnt ihr am besten hat mir den
kontakt treten am besten auf facebook
jetzt einem auch in der video
beschreibung das sagen jetzt einfach mal
den zum ersten video und ich freue mich
schon immer mal wieder zu sehen
ein name fällt erstmal urlaub auf jeden
fall sagen ich haut rein und jede
schwarze einem ferien
[Musik]